вуса вид буває сопить покровом ночі
порту одеси до вайс перли не чорного
моря
більярду знаку і тут у темних каналах
вантажникам так шлюбу я українському місцю
троє вирішу чиїх людей хоче в ряду від
цих гаю для audi сайту куті сили
вину корупції олена васина у ліжко до
Юлія Марушевська поборницею
Михайло Саакашвілі
анти корупціонер
до пізньої ночі want ачивкою прибуває у
порт нічого він і звучного путінці
вираз у малого
20 особисто журналістка олена васина
ранку мало пивну інформацію адже худше
фантазії wog
тут у євротерміналі
явно на всі види вається законно
шкіра монтаж у каповій на плати ти
заїсть за обслуговування і все начхати
не фірмі
Аліна пил нас підстерігає авторів uid
і
що впадай їй у vici
ви не пропускаєте ще в стравах.
картелю тут все дають мільйони
відповідно починаємо ж ви видного
починаючи чому ви ліжок у снт палив
починаючи
спинку в тис з людьми злодії ми з
поліцією чиновникам і ми відразу повз що
адже це просто проти схема
як дозволяючи одному приватному досвіду
наступність мат іп рибу так вид монтажу
потік weekly пряму
одеський порт який прямує в
одеський порт з функцією та й таким чином
за кілька місяців занесе і вигідні твій
євротерміналу у 20 різних місцях
встановлені нові дорожні знаки
оператор олійник вуса знімаємо
ти знак прямого you'd want помилкою до
євротерміналу
це один з але c1 та нові знаки вікі я
казав зупиняй буквально васани
монологу руку для того, щоб жалобу вати
шляхи кванта живий для того, щоб стримати його
ти його позбавив одним шляхом позбавляючи через
євро термінал ікла ван теж не може
проїхати та далі місяця у ви не not ми
проїхали пари християн і по ви ними
пубертат і вище там у демонтажі волає
верчу і t через у підлоги аллена
поставлялася знаки геть і в принципі
заражаєте 1000 заражати але просто
минулим та та
а до чого порушимо у нас кроїти ми в
машині минулого тієї інакше я не зможемо
так до 4000 want ачивок мало не про
направляє до євротерміналу вуса та груші
і дує даних ти мулині вантажники ніби з
прямого не на тому ж порту поліпшення
інфраструктури порту тут можна ремонтувати
Під'їзний шлях все завищується в тему
євротерміналі так і дайте про 200 тисяч
доларів ще дня важкий був у вас піт
ринку політики vpn аолена
у карти люку ви небудь і світський аж у
найвищих холах за словом та журналістки
заниженою у тему і мер одеси
люди на старій рудій його підозрювати у
зірок як за організовану випадковістю
чи ні роботи у всіх оружні не як що
воно хочеш викройкою картель маленькі
журналісти та офіс машини відриваючи пити
ринку то фінансуючи свої розслідування
за крима дещо мені з вул і не джен і
раз брала інтерв'ю у мера труханова я
кивав ідея процвітаючу будемо вільну
компанію його їм я постіль повезу і
страхуванням податливий то відьми ванням
гарне питання
усі кадри з євротерміналу журналістам
на дав і на умовах анонімності перед
кожним випуском шкіри наш сюжет виду
є юристи дорогах юри дачного тим
курей мови топити бирка фактору я все
фактору дістати нюта сюжет не виходьте в
ефір для свого фільму онлайн озу стріла
сі ес нову голову умити знайти після
призначення марушевська уа ла силла
вину випадковості у ким чи може 26 річкова
література знаються прям ух ти служіння
бант у груповий друк протестів на
майдані у 2014 уроки
Юлія Марушевська стала знаменитою за
одну нитку за дику в'язницю за o'clock
овен ви назвав таїться досвід про ханян
Петро та мото українців про боротьбу за
свободу відео про глянув і мільйони
коростове chef жінка стала одним з у
бути майдану то диво допоможе їй скоро ти
ти роздутий чиновницький апарат на тему
і на таки
усвідомлював і пара sky
владний апорт них був таємницею великим
жерлом про будку для місця нібито на
мафіозні групи vanish година дев'яностих
руки
турі для вулик і це зерном тут досі
ється в обсі державі
мало дакаре поза темою знайти хоче значати
ці структури та їм це у нових
відомству
в ноги і чи будемо зістригти з
архітектором і архітектура ви на увазі
бра стиснутої пружини з мильницею наук
видно для such a основу мити його
контролю
сторони на тир1 ську годину уаз обливала
корупцію то хабар спорідненість
вона по ви на знак ну ти ново будемо ляма
я сама лизавати вигляд крити є раз по
виду і марушевська у років часто не
чи будемо ми від протитоку 70 нових
spears hipsters у мід знайти розбудила не
за принципами ви підкова sti
дієго і за сип проти корупції та й
кісти врубає на кой проц його лише з
пивними компаніями та всі вуса him були
так би можуть обривати не митники
cs prof дід вже давно і погано ситуація
у явити себе ще
зарплат не митник зупиніть близько від
10 доларів, а побачили старійшині
океани біля хвали вали був і
на мільйони гривень у майбутньому
митники по ви не ранку йому вати краще
зарплат не порушуючи охочі під бате
про тещу в ньому ближче ти на своїй про
будки
1 хороший для чого вона поки не травня у
планах також нова процедурам затишного
контролю з гіпноз якою прийми контакти
між іт на комусь експедитором за
вийдуть до мінімуму
таким чином залякувати муть незаконним
зло вам
марушевська за проводила дадуть каву змін
і для будильники
ви на хочеш обновлена ​​установа запитувала
якумо ваш ви че у team ініціативи
початковий тимут знайти регулярно блок
адже затишно у її владному відомстві спер
у битники домагаються бучу завалить
зрадам я відразу мило на скільки болю
снують анни в успішну повинен і б
суцільне бюрократія
я видела як вона руїну і рожевий струм як
вона руїну я
інвестиційний клімат для мене це
проекту ножах якову я чоловіку труби tt за
рогачова ми стояли на майдані
майдан порт цілий show dance фронті фф
помруть без корупції
губернатор одещини саакашвілі бореться
на кіль коп фронту одну приватну пізню
вечора when we відкриваючи новий центр
обслуговування громадян мер одеси колії
в'язницю за води ти знову корпусів він і
владних у кіри задушить рецепт зарядку
ми карнивал з перу hipster в три місяці
він і вчилася небезпечних офісі обслуга ось
це допомагає і здобутій параді
а місця сказала ми не тому вам повну
зарплату а шляхом вона домагалася я
привести людей і кіно тирново не тільки
старатися стояла протеїн акша чи треба
всі посли в гру mario нам по ви не треба
увійти setup bios бюрократична ці
ганелін і босха барів яга у грузії пояс
її саакашвілі пресі
тайвін успішно подолав побутову корупцію
українку руб tewin на тіло вся і на
організовано випромінювання але в проліті
спеціального призначення протиотруту
на випадуть zoho плані а за ручники у
даси диска поліція славилася навмисним
що була замішана в турі для наркотиків
це позика лосяра котон де ла рів
держава піп війна за б сховають особини
монополію сили та позначаючи жадібних
приватних соловки для олігархи
лісових копальні в травні буде йому позаду і в
Цьому й у разу судачок mesh скальним їжу
насильства стрибаємо на кому це
противником та влади
щоб не повторилася, а ти зараз столиця
в одесі іншого травня
2014 року
то дієв тему будинку прав spylog заварив
і 42 проросійські антимайдани нафти в не
за барикаду волосся у чи буде parade
in with був і посуд окуляри за активістами
майдану коктейлі молотова сс причини
лижах la його пізніше сьогодні відразу милу
що пожежної кота поліції у працю ви
через тупізну поїв вручена
потрійного не це уніформу над ходом з
америки і канади і японії це на вигляд
мера труханова жадібна піт ринку ми на
мага і муся пофарбує та підготовку води
хочемо працювати з приватними втратами
і фірми обручі полунин відходить і вигляд у
ряду ще принц і я була на занижену і
ніхто на них стукають осі вели роботу
через seven ж із глини 26 карина ківі
білки в поліції саакашвілі наводить лад
для росіян будемо одеси рука і нами на
південь безслідно на реставрацію шлюбу та
грушею
коло ті буквально роз'їла місця
Олена давно врятував 3-го я потім я калли
капелюх орли на чорному морі та так
ліберж і за нападаючи
віконце науки геною та санацію знаку it
темними каналами і до того ж мої дружини
пити спадкоємство не плакати по дотці
за не подає силі райони місця для будки
порту булып богатой изменит и
закритість та її причини розслідування
Олени такі важливі ви на передала
обрану інформацію але в голові та
митниця таза ікла лаку рюкзаки в
євротерміналу треба ти куля станемо uuid
адже ті запалював і допомогти а ти доведи
аллена за неспокій на ох чувак геть і
заводити у прилюдно new year і бур теж
подав простягни і позов
це перше ось cqb перший від самих суду
ви так і поклик тупцювати вперше вона ж
підготовка до суду така duty лугів
моральний тест можна сказати to the
bleeding і ну не вміє шахті гуашшю до
наших сюжетів
інших сюжетів bleeding та bull і тата
реджине я був випробувай від самого
рального піску
морального тиску а жерти там добрина
війни одеської митниці подала документи
у національному терорі корупційне бюро
щодо прикриття водіям який
відмовляється їхати через плавну
майданчик загрожує штраф 255 гривень таким
Таким чином праворуч євротерміналу вивішу в цю
муть на вищому рівні в віч його я підлогу
екшен
у team поршнів головне антикорупційне
відомство України розслідуючи справу можемо
і ну ти багата години тим часом лайна
взявся за еньші розслідування одеса
відома та книжечку румб про ван та місця
україни в російській літературі на ідиші
шифру і часто потрапляв і сам і суди з
швидко на мого ніку в хату і тут
звучним я речам досить безтурботно
атмосфера але він це ще озираєшся
віч його їж погляд у спину
я обіцяю собі на вигляд ти на днк з на
знаємо їх але ми риф то чоловіки знаєш що
тобі телефону та вівці та момент
її відкрийте я закликав і dota ще
вісім корумпованих чиновників
мусовий 5 врятував від того часу журналістка
не раз від removal про загрозу червоною багата
шквальним видом kef вчинку у втомилася не
українців дуку руб ті змінюється при
гасимо молодь досі ікона нащу її можна
повороти фільми олени вселяються віру в
людей
тебе пісні просвічені з цілісним цуценям
україни нікіфор сують змін і
звинувачую немає на сьогодні
всі
ми зараз
та ще не змінюються ніколи на приклад
гри в карти проц старому ринку привезу
центрі одеси
так тут було ще зара дитячих частиною
ставки граф тиф на великому
out на ринку і дайте прозору пак і
алленів же кілька місяців проводить тут
розслідування ви нас вазі тягнучи
земельна ділянка
на якорі сташований ринок на вижити
картелю століття і пов'язує Олександром
ангар там ведену кримінальну посаду
ж dice і тут його так вже називається
ангелом вин розбагатівши на контрабанді
оружі це рецидив 12 роки повіти ті
забув
труханов називаючи його своїм другом
ділянку продав і картелю за смішні речі
дусі 2 drink у та девів чорний холдинг
наки 3 років і практично не платити за
дотці на томі скупого та тире чиновники
взяткою і на камеру той процес ніхто не
хоче оберти
до 90 так з дев'яностих руки ви готові
волосся куртина схема корупції на
систем акули bigeye з фінансових
потоків на ринку височіла разом ми
йшли на фінансування московському бюджету
піт ринку одеси ішиду тіньових структур
як місцях так і закордонних
Аліна вдягаєте що генеральна
прокуратура наріжте візьмуться за справу
мій же psy ринку кудись це на підлозі
противитися подібними схемами їх також
називають спіральним та машинками для
грушею речовин reboot кісти трохи в сум
не поза каналом та громадою ранковим йому я
практично нічого
на вулиці постійний кота торговці разів
повідають нам загину
азербайджанець Михайлу продає тут овочі
вже 30 руки аліхора
Ісус та олігархи що скажемо а корупція
мафія у їхніх руках ццц з них руках
мало на ляже й українські народи
українські народи мені вона ніби вона
українка народу повинна проводитися
щоб продавати і тут свою жаль chewing
повинен регулярно давати і хабара
посередником
позбавивши грузії успішно поборов і корупцію
кожен михайлов та зведу поїду до
сусіднім околицям і я дуже хотів би
захочу я буду жаба жаба була каширина
wave на привезенні лад студія кажу ще
wedge їхніх місцях для нього все швидкою їм
я купила у грузії саакашвілі ци в
далласе обожнюємо і хайло купа республіка
була на та corum на зовнішній вигляд у радіанс каму
метушні
одеса
велике ви ікло в тіла не реформи мало
перед ворітьми стогін дивитися на всю
україни та від президента грузії
саакашвілі за дули корупцію на і не
вин хоче труби тец а і в Україні
1:05 б ти борщі піцу mk ii
на прокиньте 2015 руку губернатор
саакашвілі зібрів
у істерично можуть або бристоль
антикорупційний форум голеним проц його
the goodies even запити в ній
активних реформаторів за всю Україну
губернатор ну 3 травня науки нам Петро
шматка його на адже поки його вислугу
них тиші в одесі всі сфери су
спинного ж тебе corum кого не кожевин у
школах та університетах чи коренях і сюди
дають хабарі через c держава зустрічаючи
тягнучи з неї суми, що вросли вище в
одесі 5 мільярдів доларів ось вісь у
чому є корупцією корупція для
стріляли зуй окраїну то крути я постіль
ставить під загрозу
державність реально рука руку ми всі
помруть
доля і нацбанк і репетує через
прем'єр-міністром та україною депутати
гостя до ситуацій хто зачеп раду з
медальний
я не знаю у нормальних країнах за все
панує побач а голова у ряду
рівні 2015 руку саакашвілі викл
акколаду криво конфлікт у ту зайвою
учням уряду яценюком за газ 3 вся
саакашвілі на полі хвиля тому що ряд
бій кутуючи важливі віра форми за помічаючи
ніхто так не розбавляючи з міністра
внутрішніх справ аваковим саакашвілі
стоять і дали великим критиком і ряду в
києві
пасту по вас я відразу милу
що вин і в Україні хоче град і в
вищипали точніше лізі профільних і
саакашвілі на вигляд забирає наказано
про значення політика главою ряду ми нас
по діваються ще саакашвілі мить без that
is a mighty нею крижану я багаття було без
україни успішно україну
виловом відзначимо руйнувалися kdd чи далі
конфліктуючи за владним та колегам і вона
дзвеніла мій же всіх камінь ми таких-то
начальники у вигляді ліф проти протони
доросла
він майдани та always на майдані ми завжди
знав їх то наша купа протоколом убори
мощь and here а тут ти нікулін і плавний
від жертви купа і на дію колега і
людей я не знаю
бюрократи равликів і а от як
приймання отримав шанс
мати бізнес цінових від овочів ти маєш
подумати і 2 4 тим як труби ти нас тут
ний круг адже андуїн для кс тис так і ми
катастрофічним та виставкам і на початку
2016 ялинку губернатор ви рушницю смаку нею
україна їм і сюди venza пройшла в на
антикорупційний форум і за у хочу вам
реформаторі
в Україні до процесорів arm його не було
закладено треба його багата вантажі нік по
між би краще мало та зведу в бутові
владної україни після ріс під
уральського союзу
клінтону виймає в Україні жадібних
Куньївський світських там у них і запити
українці при завданні та ряд збоїв
момент для теми не важливі в їх реформах
образу писали ров людей на майдані
поважаючи саакашвілі менш у сина багата
складні ши в силу св дом людь підвищується
обман часу
доки українці втратити віру в реформи
у прилюдний у лютому телерепортаж олени
про євротермінали ланки в баху то шуму
отчитку показала я до духу девід
монтажних поривів за не осідають у картелі
то покриваються мером трухановим win with
кредо і все званого дуже я є
лобістом цього підприємства
партнером цього підприємства але я всіляко
підтримував колись ми на сесії
міської ради виділяли землю під
євро термінал тому що підприємство з
дуже важливе завдання для міста ім я
труха нападуть, а вже спливаючи в панамських
документах якщо ці протестували
kicking одних блоку вал їх хітами
сковороди одеси, що допомагають вид ставкою
мера оша труханів розпочатого в ідея 20 ма
офшорним фірмам і он і обіцяє
Забілін це доступ думали лиж і т.д.
кулигін склади положення
ути мер караючи русь ігната
демонстрацію
владних та євротерміналу виступають fruit
& alan та річ у тому що право у тому ще
ніхто не любить cool та викроюють схеми
ці патенти на мої дихають і сирте нею
то багатий уроки в схема ви готові
ється йому на завищується в тіні зовсім і
на з милими журналісти я коліно багаті
зараз руйнувалася місці відповідно це
видно з результату і радіє покази
чим і
nidorina робом у свою роботу і наша
праворуч наш сюжет і знаходите вигляд звуку
і ціру сліди в цьому і цінно тиш високому
рівні вищому рівні олени годинника
навідується так дзвонова
коворкінг-центр вибоїн разом з зустріч
молодих людей і кіку many cultures
інтернет за цим святим тут молоді
українців заснували свої інтернет
стартапи журналістка 40 однодумців
то часто диску тут про труханова то
корупцію сара чиновники чи то депутатів
багатих того хрестові свої посади за
для з багатшим не зассі протезе прозорець
розчарувати цей називається електронна
демократія має прийоми подрібнює
формуляр куркуму чиновники то політики
молитві відкрито вказуйте свої доходи
путінці розставляти та каламутити в інтернет
доступна у ранку maruchas або skype я з
її губернатору перед пресою махінації
картеля деки дорожній знак і поставив їх
а за південь управління просто в нього перед
носом провокація
саакашвілі допомагаючи повного пояснення
поїхали подивимося
edition pro мільярди
то про мій будь не порту порушивши сказав
у чаю найкраще here is the exporter
за де кіпр і but can with poor туманом
кута ви буду ось цю частину нова циpка
rouge не промисловці спадкоємство c район
вже давно ніхто не інвестую вам
саакашвілі вже на зуб і немає і знак і по
ви не знак ну ти за раз термінів у
губернатора за будь-якою боротися за це
волосся наруч для юлії марушевської цивіки
успіх
l і витівок простіше
я ви буду і розумним цю систему базар
османи моєму достатньо кішки в на ces
dog та всі знак та будуть di mantova не
монтаж гнучкою чи треба лається на
премку
євротермінала теж бульбаш віддала кабель
завершення у team олена васина
Юлія Марушевська то Михайло Саакашвілі
здається, що їх так легко
на вигляд для коте